uh early in your career you got to work
with sonny chiba um and i just have to
know because i don't often get to talk
to people who worked and studied under
sunny what was that experience like
yeah um
when i was a
child actor
age five
i played his son role in the yakuza
movie and then it was a black and white
movie
and then
i worked
with him
many times then i joined to his action
club when i was 13.
so um
yeah i learned a lot from him and then
yeah
he taught me a lot jumping into bullet
train one of the things that is so cool
about the movie is this not only is the
action well done and it's very stylized
and just well directed but the script
keeps you guessing in terms of what
exactly is going on and who did what uh
what was that one of the things that
drew you in was uh after reading this
basically um just talk a little bit
about the script if you don't mind yeah
when i i first read the script i was so
excited
because my role elder has a own history
background
and family drama
and a revenge story
all in one
with the action and the little comedy
sense so i thought oh this script has a
great balance between drama action
comedy thriller
uh
great adaptation from the novel
so
yeah
i
i could believe people waiting for this
kind of movie
especially after
during the pandemic you know
it's kind of movie
make love and exciting
uh moment
yeah i i could believe
it's gonna be a great movie
one of the things that i just can't
believe about this film is that
basically the entire thing was shot on
the sony backlot on a sound stage yeah
you can't believe when you're watching
the movie that that's where you shot it
can you sort of talk about the fact that
that you really only shot it on a sound
stage for the most part yeah they
created the you know
great train and then platform
in the
studio when i
saw them oh my gosh i'm so happy to be
here
uh it's exactly the
movie set
and uh
great scale
and
detail was so perfect
and i felt like i'm
staying in the real station or sometimes
real
train
and all almost all all in the studio so
ah i was so happy
excited my last question for you i am a
huge fan of the john wick movies i mean
a huge fan i've seen that we premiered
the footage for john wick four during my
comic-con panel oh
yeah kevin was there chad wasn't there
exactly so um i saw your character in
the footage what can you tease people
about the movie and who you play yeah
maybe footage
showed
that relationship between
keanu and i
so i worked with keanu
before in the 47 running
and
[Music]
the kind of
relationship with knowing each other a
long time
so we could use that
chemistry into the movie
so that's that
big hint i think i'll leave it there i
cannot wait to see it uh i wish you
nothing but the best thank you so much
for giving me your time thank you so
much
you